faire de l'ancien collège jules régler
un espace de vie vos idéaux savoir faire
c'est ainsi que nassimah dindar
présidente du conseil général a imaginé
ce lieu désormais les dionysiens peuvent
prendre possession de ce site où la
nature a été reconstitué c'est
l'association des anciens de régler qui
a participé à cette reconstruction était
enseignant ici pendant trente ans on
passe pas 30 ans de vraiment droit sens
y est attaché j'étais très très attaché
à ce collège est ma plus grande crainte
c'était donc de le voir rasé et c'est
d'ailleurs ce qui était prévu de faire
des barres d'immeubles
on avait parlé à l'époque de 230
logements donc quand je vois ce que ce
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui je ne peux être
que ravi
les renseignements
on n'aura pas des associations aura des
salles magnifiques de lieux il
appartient pas seulement à ceux qui
habitent le bas d'arriver à la
petite-fille de la police il appartient
aux dirigeants
il appartient aux réunionnais je
voudrais vraiment que tout ce qui a été
fait ici puissent servir d'exemple sur
le modèle de l'insertion par
l'économique parce que il faut de la
solidarité sociale mais à la solidarité
sociale
il y a aujourd'hui l'exigence d'apporter
de la solidarité l'économique des caches
pauvres mais également des petits bancs
sur lesquels on tresse des bandes de
bâche recyclée des mutuelles
but c'était comment c'était pas
compliqué puisque j'étais dans le voter
c'est très beau et puis
faire de la répu travail et la
récupération ça pour rien
un parc qui donne envie de flâner et qui
pousse à la rêverie des murs végétaux
des sculptures c'est surtout les
artisans qui sont invités à s'installer
ici à l'image de l'atelier oued coyah
ville qui permet aux habitants du
quartier de créer leurs objets ont
répondu boire pourra pour faire des
petits carrés alors primes et dépôts de
fleurs
pour l'atelier bois de goyavier il
s'agit aussi d'exposer de vendre les
objets et l'immeuble fabriquer ce mois
dépend de l'établissement dessus et les
personnes qu'il y aura demain vous
travaillez l'espace riquet accueille
aussi un autre artisan qui maîtrise le
travail du bois de châtaignier la bouffe
là on l'a fait en huit exemplaires
un peu plus loin la bibliothèque
départementale comme à l'accoutumée à
réaliser une décoration magnifique et
aujourd'hui cet atelier pour les plus
petites
l'espace rennais est une respiration
pour toutes les familles de saint denis
est d'ailleurs un espace qui leur
permettra de s'adonner à une passion ou
encore à transmettre leur passion
car les associations sont appelés à
s'installer sur ce site
et pour ceux qui ont la main verte mais
qui n'ont pas de cours un champion
participatif leur permettra de cultiver
des fruits des légumes de planter des
fleurs et ainsi se retrouver au grand
air